[Music]
so
good evening and welcome to my trip
first ever live stream guys
and um before we do anything else
explain spence
okay so
basically i wanted to like dress up a
little bit i'm wearing my i'm wearing my
star wars t-shirt um but i wanted to
represent the trek side so i thought i'd
do some some trill markings on myself
um and what i didn't realize
is i'd accidentally used a permanent
marker
um so i now have
some some very nice drill markings
permanent marker on my face
uh let's see how that goes when i try
and wipe those off
yeah if you don't have a symbiote pouch
you're just not serious so let's see
i i personally love the commitment to it
and that you you you did this so that we
had something to laugh at you
well it wasn't intentional but hey here
we go
hey i'm going to take
i'm going to be doing this side on the
whole time
excellent okay good just stop just don't
be pouting and things because it's a bit
but
exactly so this evening we're going to
have a little bit of a chat about star
wars and star trek and this is a comment
that you made spent actually and that
that have they lost their way
in the last few years these tv shows
that we love the two the two big boys in
in sci-fi you know we can have another
debate about whether stargate's better
personally i i quite like stargate
exactly
but for this evening
so first of all we're going to say what
do we actually think like the identity
of star wars and star trek is what do we
mean by or what do we think that if
they've lost their way a little bit
how you know where were they to begin
with does that make sense
what do you think spent
star trek i think it's easy one of the
two
well i mean for me it's a case of you
know i suppose they've evolved over time
haven't they so it's a case of you know
star wars for example
started out it's it's
it's not science fiction it's science
fantasy you know it's stylistic it's
inspired by
um
samurai movies swashbuckling movies um
you know when it came to the prequel
trilogy it was very much about you know
sort of political intrigue stuff like
that um
and then
the the sequel trilogy very much just
turned for me into generic action
space films
and it's the same with um with star trek
for me as well you know i grew up
watching
um tng deep space nine voyager
um
i'll be honest with you guys i haven't
watched all of enterprise i i couldn't
deal with it but at the same time like
the the structure for it you know it was
very philosophical moral questions you
know um you know ds9 really pushed it to
the limit of that but there was still
this hopeful ideology behind it um and
now it's
punchy kicky shooty generic action space
tv show for me
during that deep space nine episode i
think it was season six
when cisco was actually talking to the
camera
oh
yeah when he framed uh
yeah
the uh fake hologram describing the uh
invasion of romulus plans yeah when he
was when he was he teamed up with
garrick
in the very end of the episode he's
doing a captain's log in the very end of
the episode he just like delete vlogs so
i think yeah he's talking about yeah
like mass murder and they you know
how far the war had pushed them you know
and this is the time was it just
the first iraq war just ended and but
the war
911
at the impact it would have had some
phenomenal episode that's that's what i
love about patrick is it reflects
society a lot of the time it actually
reflects
our best and our worst
um elements in my life um there's so
much about like transgender and stuff as
well
in deep space nine
um
yeah yeah particularly with drill
particularly yeah
i don't know how they had actually um
like um
they had a the the two trill kiss didn't
they don't say other relationship but at
no point did they actually reference any
sort of like transgender issues or
something that the point of the episode
was that they're not supposed to because
the symbionts had a relationship
previously so they're not supposed to
have like a relationship in the
in in their new forms sort of thing yeah
um
but really i mean that's that's why i
love it it was really about sort of
transgender and relationships i mean
um
well even the uh klingons handled it
better than most politicians in america
i mean you know when korg you know when
he first met uh jazia dax he said oh my
old friend curzon
i loved that call back to tos as well
getting those guys back in also in the
new makeup with no explanation i loved
it yeah yeah yeah
in disco i think they've done that
because of the
the new series so didn't they with the
where they changed the klingons again do
you love how i love that um episode it's
not the first time the klingons have
changed the makeup look is it and i
actually do remember they they did that
brilliant another another deep space
nine i think these were nice it's
seriously underrated sometimes
did that series when they jumped back to
the original series the trouble with
tribbles
and these nine characters went back and
actually
and i think that wasn't that one of the
tail end uh episodes of enterprise
dna or something yeah yeah that's it
yeah there was something augmented dna
wasn't there yeah and then they just did
it again
i i don't like the klingons now i think
they look weird
and particularly
what in discovery yeah i just think they
look but they just look odd
that one the the one female character
in discovery um no not in this yeah in
the first
yeah she just looks strange just looks
weird well i mean okay so i've got some
opinions i was actually going to dive in
on some some more critical stuff but i'm
actually going to defend discovery on
this in that if you look at
the the klingon makeup and the way that
the headpieces rest in tng ds9 etc
you've got that double nostril approach
like okay yeah you never see the bat
well you do in um in one of the movies
see the back of back one of their heads
but you know other than that i mean it's
very
it's very similar makeup i mean it's
maybe more enhanced it's maybe a bit
more modern um but i've i mean i've got
massive problems with the the new star
trek series which we'll get onto
but at the same time i think the way
that they handle the klingons other than
yes there was the initial baldness which
they say was
part of like wartime klingon culture and
culture is uh transitional it changes um
and and i mean other than
that and the fact that they were
stockpiling the coffins as opposed to
the the shell
um attitude that they had in in
you know next generation onwards which
is if a klingon dice it's just a shell
other than that i
i actually really liked the depiction of
the klingons in discovery i think
particularly um and he was only in it
for two episodes but the actor that
played to kuvmah in the first two
episodes
that guy sold it i mean you can tell
that guy learnt his klingon lines you
know remain klingon
boom like it was the the guttural
approach to the pronunciation and even
with those facial prosthetics like he
really sold it for me um so i actually i
saw a documentary i kept watching the
post discovery you know they did the
post discovery episodes on netflix when
it first came out yeah yeah yeah
talking klingon off
characteristic he didn't break character
and says it was really frustrating
i was i was i was gutted that they they
i mean spoiler alert but i'm gutting
he died after the second episode because
that guy was like the best klingon actor
out of anyone he put his soul into i was
i was so impressed it was amazing it was
good
really good
the um
his acting skills yeah i mean
when i first started watching discovery
you know the first time it came on you
know i signed up for cbs all access
totally ready to nerd out
and
of all the other actors he's i mean he
stole everything he didn't even know
what i mean even with all the makeup he
stole every scene he was in
it was that bit where he was saying
about when he was and i don't remember
obviously i didn't speak klingon but
like um apart from a couple of phrases
but when he was talking about he was
saying uh the federation is is is down
in the muck with the andorians and the
and the vulcans and all this and it was
it was you know the tellerites and it
was oh my god like the guy was
incredible the cool and the way he you
know he was talking about you know the
relationship between klingons and the
federation well the federation everybody
and here comes the lie
yeah you know and then um georgios says
and we come in peace
yeah well it may have it may have been i
mean in a way i i think they missed out
on an opportunity to to compare that as
almost like a borg comparison because
the way to cover it was it was an
assimilation of their culture and
denying them their individuality as a
spacefaring race
um you know and if that's something
we've never seen like or at least i
don't remember seeing with klingons is
that attitude if you know the
federation's trying to tame us and take
our culture away you know obviously
yeah what we know about it
in ds9 you know just a slight a little
bit but not as pronounced as tacoma's
declaration you know
yeah before though is the federation
america
you know they're the good guys they
always say they're the good guys you
know we come in peace
shoot to kill you to kill [ __ ]
so they were shooting discovery which is
one of my problems with it i i would say
like the um
i'm blanking on who it would be but
whoever the most chaotic society is in
uh
the in the uh
uh trek universe would probably be
america you know it's
i mean we're having people riot at
school board meetings because they're
asking children to wear a mask during a
global pandemic so
even the ferengi knew blowing up bombs
in your atmosphere was bad for the
planet
yeah
yeah and they were very
very commerce based
if we're talking about like
star trek losing its identity though are
we really focusing on discovery or are
we thinking as well i mean did actually
enterprise start down this road of
forgetting
what it was supposed to be
my personal experience i think
enterprise was just too complicated i
think they over did it
and i think if they just simplified that
storyline it could have really been
brilliant
but i think they have all the time
travel stuff and the time or things and
if they just dropped that
and done a series
like t and g
you know just like we're going to go to
a different planet each week we're going
to build up and they're building towards
the federation it would have been
awesome but then all this
crap they threw on top sorry
yeah
the the schism between um
star or humans and vulcans god that was
delicious i thought you know
and um
how you know how the the dependence
humans had on vulcans and the submissive
role that humans had with vulcans
you know and uh especially the um
you know finding the listening post in
the uh temple oh yeah that was one of my
favorite episodes of the whole thing you
know it had nothing to do with the sula
bond had nothing to do
you know i i did kind of like the um
the whole arc with the um
the zindy
you know especially
yeah production of florida and that was
kind of cool but so like i agree with
you guys the whole the time travel thing
and the zipping around and
uh it was just nonsense and then they're
talking about that that that might be
coming back through into enterprise
don't as well you know like the um the
guy from the future whenever we saw his
face he looked kind of looked like a
romulan to me i always thought but um he
was you know like talking to the people
they think that's the guy or the one of
the fan theories is the another guy in
enterprise in the third series and he
keeps talking to um oh forgotten her
name the captain from
uh the mirror universe
in in in them
ah in discovery oh what's your name
oh george
is
they think it's him
they think he's the guy that is that
like the face from the future sort of
thing i the one thing i love about that
though is when they had this did the
kelvin
um universe so they did the jj abrams
films they had little bits from
um
those two films in the dino he that bit
of the start where he's driving the car
and it goes over the cliff that's right
that's that's where there's indie fire
the weapon
and then obviously in the third film we
actually see
a um an archer class sort of thing you
know like the the enterprise sort of
version of the starship as well and i
was i always liked that
um
they seem to respect enterprise more
than the
yeah i mean
i mean i've just full disclosure with
you guys like i've seen all of tos all
of tng all of deep space nine all
voyager i have not watched all of
enterprise i could not get on board with
it um discovery i've seen one two and
some of three and i've seen all of
picard um but i've kind of like i ran
out of steam enterprise and i ran out of
steam with um discovery
and i've definitely run out of steam
with picard um
and then i think we're also we're
getting very star trek heavy here i mean
we haven't even started
star wars in a second
i think you should give discovery season
three another try that mate to be fair
because it's the best series
yeah it greatly improves it's really
really good
you know stuff the the storyline and
you're on to something new
you know it's uh
it's because
i i i
really enjoyed discovery season one i
really enjoyed it and i thought i would
be properly against it when it first
started because the initial episode
started and within 10 minutes we had
holograms
that's that's not all friendly and we
had the the change for klingons and i
went yeah screw this uh and then i stuck
it through i really enjoyed the first
series
i enjoyed the second series up to about
halfway through and i got fed up
um and then picard came out
and i don't know if this is a
controversial opinion the card's
freaking awful in my opinion awful awful
training so come back in a sec but let's
just focus on disco for one second
because okay
discovery gets good
i i'm with you to be fair i didn't
really watch the end the second half of
the discovery series
and i what i did was when discovery
series three came out i thought i'm
gonna have to figure out what happened
so i sort of went back and and and got
up to but to be honest two or three
episodes i don't think i actually
watched and i just watched enough that i
knew what the hell was going on so i
think and then i got into discovery
because i knew they've gone into the
future so i was like i want to see
what's in the future that that's that's
good no this is really good idea
brilliant
but then it took half the series for you
to actually see the federation actually
see anything in the future that's it i
got i got two three episodes in and i
was like
sorry guys but when they do me
and the little nod the nog because
obviously the the nog actor um passed
away didn't he was it last the year
before yes
i believe his name was yeah
so one of the starships actually is the
nog and you actually do see it pretty
good
oh no way yeah yeah so i'm saying
actually
before we started this storm uh my my
business partner mike um who i'm also on
aliens and stuff with um who
unfortunately couldn't make it today um
him and i were meant to go to
destination track
and we were going to get a uh photo with
nog ron and quark in full costume and we
didn't go
off till the next year but of course the
next year was covered and it was
cancelled and now unfortunately he's um
passed away so
we've got if we missed out on that
opportunity i love to knock in deep
space nine that was some real character
development right there
yeah all the all the ferengi were
brilliant in d space nine
i think d space nine might be my
favorite series it's my favorite it's
it's
yeah i mean the one thing i liked about
it is you know all the other series
we're talking about you know before and
after ds9
it was kind of the standard you know
the federations the good guys you know
it was sparkly clean earth yeah but ds9
rolled that back it showed gritty
underhanded
backstabbing semi-corrupt nature of the
federation and continuing that forward
that thought forward to
discovery
the discovery was a button there are
spoilers in this thing but the discovery
is all about
fall of empire at least for me
yeah how you know fall of empire how
quickly it uh
um creates uh power vacuums and um
you know
that was
it was kind of interesting to see
you know and you got this one guy at
this once uh starfleet port who's been
taking care of this banner has been
passed down from his ancestors of the
federation and he's waiting for somebody
that's a commissioned officer to hang
the damn thing
and that was kind of heartbreaking you
know it's just like jeez dude
i love the whole premise of the success
it was a bit boring in the first half of
series because because of the burn the
burn limited
sort of thing and and you know against
boilers
there was this thing
i feel like i should have watched this
before today but i have one day
go back to it and we'll discuss it again
because you'll come back and go oh i
suit you me
but i i'm with you though at the first
when star trek discovery started i'm
like spore drive
right okay and then like say their their
technology was just like tng sort of
levels or even beyond and i'm so like
this doesn't make sense
like it's like
why do you keep doing prequels we don't
care
and it's like
you know
it's it's where do you say this because
my mike and i were discussing this and
we were saying do you know
if you want to have technology
that is beyond that appropriate period
just said it later i mean it made it
other than other than the spock and
sarrick reference
what difference did it make time wise
they had that they could have had a
second claim i mean they had that in the
freaking i don't know if either of you
guys played star trek online
yeah a little bit yeah there was a there
was a second klingon war so why not just
said it then if if you want to change
the law you know and i i know that it's
nitpicky but we're freaking star trek
fans like we're gonna be nitpicky that's
star trek that's what we do
so the thing that annoyed me was though
it complicates your life as the writer
because again like you said the two
things that star trek proper trekkies
have got is that we really nitpick over
the cannon
and we like that we like the story to
actually have a you know flow with
detail orientated and we like the ships
and the technology
so why do a prequel that just
complicates all of that you can't just
do whatever you want in the series i
mean that's why they did the kelvin
timeline wasn't it because
right
we'll just create this event we can
change time we can
this is a new universe now so we can do
whatever we want sort of thing
um and that's how they got around it
discovery didn't do that they just made
their lives harder so just don't just
set it just after tng ended
you know
exactly well exactly i mean the last we
saw was freaking uh
nemesis which was a
wasn't a big one
i like them you like what you like never
said yeah yeah i like the space i like
this
i liked um i liked
surprisingly i liked interaction i
thought interaction was pretty good i
saw it in the cinema when i was about
seven i loved it um
it's got a new it's got an evil admiral
it's it's a
theater when i was seven
i was still at the theater when i was
27.
you know
amy come on insurrection is awful
it's all seen no it's everything you're
just wrong expense um
and now i know why i'm in the middle
yeah exactly
right
every other star trek film generally
speaking is terrible
and that is the the odd number movie
it's it's just
bad
and first contact was incredible
insurrection was awful
um it to me it's on par with
um the final frontier
it's it's
not that bad
oh it's pretty bad
at the same time though you've got to
consider it is that um
it would have been okay if it was if it
was a an episode a mid-season episode in
say season three of tng you'd excuse it
yeah oh no don't get me wrong i still
love it because it's star trek yeah and
i love all star trek even um when they
go find god there are bits of that film
that are brilliant i love it i love the
whole stuff it's probably one of the
best stuff
i will know that there's some great
quotes out of that you know i don't
believe in a god that would uh i can't
remember your exact quote now but bones
quote but you know there were some great
great moments out of that i like that
yeah you don't ask the almighty for his
id
that's a great phone line
great bonus
should we should we should we check out
what about star wars eggs we've
completely ignored
stanford but before you get over in the
star wars there's a couple comments i
had is um
no we have yet to and and this this this
uh i'm kind of ashamed that we've gotten
to this point we haven't uh mentioned
lowered x
okay
what's your whole take on lower decks
my my the thing i love about lower decks
is that it is a bouquet
of easter eggs
oh my god
it is got i mean it's you have to watch
every episode four or five times to
catch all the damn easter eggs you just
whoever wrote it is just a complete
trekkie you just loved tng as well every
time you watch it you just go oh my god
i know what they're on about i know i
know the inside joke on that one
something looks like i mean it i mean i
you know is yeah it's meant for a
younger audience but i mean it is the
the scripts are cherry picked for the
nerdiest of the nerds
but but stormy as you've just very much
identified yes for a younger audience
but at the same time they've managed to
do the pixar thing which is where it's
aimed for a younger audience but it also
has things that appeal to an older
audience and i actually i was i was
going to come to this way later but
i personally feel the lower decks
for me was was more of an authentic star
trek series than picard was or um
discovery season two
are we allowed to talk spoilers are we
being spoilery yeah if you haven't
watched it why are you watching
the the end of um lower deck season one
it blew my mind when the bajoran
security officer got killed and why got
the thing ripped out
i was like that i felt more emotionally
moved by that after a couple of episodes
than i did at the end of um season two
of discovery like i cared so much more
about those characters even though the
comedy element was fair and it was
cartoony like i felt like they
established everybody more and maybe
that's through episodic um episode i
don't know but i it had so much more of
an impact for me yeah i don't know about
you it is a comedy it is a kids show but
the thing is it works and like the it's
the easter egg isn't it it's the i love
the thing where she's um
she's getting drunk on the romulan nail
instead
you'd think it'd be green but actually
it's blue and it's freaking awesome look
i got a bat left wait
we're watching it go with this yeah it's
that that's the thing for me it's
authentic star trek and you've seen
about how star trek's lost identity
watch picard
and then watch lower decks
which is which is star trek
it's not freaking picard
the federation aren't even in picard
except that it goes to the office once
which looks suspiciously like a bank
the federation isn't in picard and it
raises a lot of questions
yeah it looks lighter
it does gonna start like commanding it
it's
just crap and then i i put a video on
here at lilly some in picard series two
could we see the enterprise e because
all the beta cannon says actually
enterprise e
is still there and the enterprise f gets
launched five years after the card's
made and then of course
the enterprise is already in picard
because not the hologram that we see for
two seconds that doesn't prank
um you know but it's that
but those are my main problems with
picard other than the fact
the end was terrible
and those starships we see at the end
the shenghi and all those
are just bad
and apparently it was all thrown in
really last minute apparently the
creators are just like we've made picard
we have the federation on in it so we
maybe put the federation in it and it
was like a week before post-production
was supposed to end so they threw it
together and you can tell
well dude like
oh no sorry you guys stole oh yeah the
the thing i loved about picard
was
the stories that had nothing to do with
him
it was one of mine you know joining you
know coming up with the rangers and all
that i thought that was a strong
storyline and please ward somebody make
a series out of that
that was much more interesting than the
whole you know
um
i thought and and also
um
at least rikers got a ship now i mean
for god's sake i mean that was insane
orientation but the thing i liked the
most he seems to have stolen a ship i
just want i think he beamed aboard that
ship like this
or shanghai whatever it's called
which would have had a captain
yeah so how
and the country's like what
sort of mate i've this is my ship now
and i'm taking the fleet with me
and then and the fleet that's weirdly
exactly the same so we've got hundreds
of ships
i've got i've got so much to say about
that later jay so much to say
let's see one of the impulse engines
just fell off one of the ships as well
the the the other thing i liked about
the uh discovery was a similar kind of
thing
season two of discovery my favorite
thing was uh the stories are the
background with pike
you know what i'm really looking forward
to i mean
like anson mount was a stand out
he was amazing
amazing
the thing i love about that is was they
knew he kind of looked like the original
actor or enough an older version of the
original actor enough that when they
sort of did little bits where they cut
and showed you [ __ ] they didn't
bother changing
because he looks enough like him he's
like yeah it could just be him 10 years
down the road it's really good
and his acting skills are really good
and
that was fabulous the thing i think
the thing that they did with pike in
discovery that really added the
backstory to the original series pilot
was they made pike sit out
the klingon war because he was the best
of starfleet he was the best he was the
exemplary example of starfleet
and then i of course like a nerd i had
to go back and watch the original pilot
and it's like
holy [ __ ]
i mean it's like there were you know we
talked about the discrepancies in the
cannon and everything but it really it
really did
flavor that a whole lot and it kind of
explains why
you know uh spock went out on such a
limb i guess spence don't want to hear
about this
it also kind of explains why spock went
out on such a limb
to
help pike
get back to where he needed to be you
know because he you know
i mean spock met pike long long before
and so i think that was just it you know
he
i want to do a video about what we what
we hope
to see in stranger times stranger worlds
before it comes out um before the thing
so we should do it i'd love to do a
video on that yeah and how many actors
have had it can i say that normally i
was i was listening to you the entire
time it's just you raised the point and
it reminded me of something i needed to
send to myself which i'll bring up in a
bit
so i was listening teaser
i'm jesus now the you know talking about
spoilers one thing i always do is i
never read
geek press you know so if you know
there's like when a movie's coming out i
don't want to know anything about the
plot because there's always plot
spoilers or such and such as in the
movie i try
to really um say
yeah
and it really [ __ ] me once
really screwed me over i was living in
san francisco in the san francisco
cinema society they did a viewing of a
movie called bottle shock right
okay you guys probably never heard of
bottle shock is a little tiny indie
movie it was entertaining i loved it you
know so you know that i think it was uh
the the director is there and one of the
stars of the show so we all you know it
was the cinema side we always chat with
everybody nobody knew anybody from
anybody
but what i didn't know
was
the one uh the the guy that played beau
barrett which was
at this uh
at this
whining cheese party for bottle shock
was [ __ ] chris pine and he just
rapped
re i know right and he just snapped on
the j.j abrams first star trek film i
had no idea who he was oh my god
talking about you know what it's like to
film in napa what's his favorite wine do
you know how many hangovers he had that
was what was i did it it got [ __ ]
he was such a good kirk as well yeah so
wait if there's someone
coming they're reckoning
we're gonna get another jj abrams star
trek we think
it was it was off the cards for a long
time but it looks like it might i'm
going to tentative he didn't he did a
damn in my opinion a damn fine job like
i mean
like
better than discovery did in terms of
upgrading the technology but keeping it
similar um you know uh
yeah it was a different team dynamic but
it was a team nomadic i enjoyed you know
like it didn't deviate too far they i
mean they did the same thing with the
klingons you were talking earlier on
about the the
redesign where it came from i think
it was yeah i mean it was basically
other than the double nostril is
basically the same thing into
class classic star trek as far as i'm
concerned i thought it was yeah yeah
yeah totally i loved it um but once
again i hate to say this guys we haven't
talked about star wars yet
no no but we can let's
just say let's just keep it like
there's so many there's so many
crossovers between the issues with the
two that's all i'm saying but like jay
you're you're you're you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're okay you're doing your name no no
we're we are co-hosts
and if you are willing to draw all over
your face for this episode then you are
allowed to uh to take the lead
occasionally well i didn't i didn't
think it was permanent but i'm gonna be
committed
yeah i've got i'm gonna have a very very
awkward week next week with um the
council in the nhs but who cares i'm
good oh you don't walk into a hospital
jesus christ oh no no you've got a
client um
okay so let's talk about star wars um
because the the unique thing about star
wars is i mean obviously we have the
with star trek we've got the initial
series and then we've had next-gen ds9
and voyager have all come within years
of each other so there's kind of like uh
and obviously a lot of people didn't
like um tng when it came out they were
like this isn't expected you know
um you know and and whereas some people
didn't like deep space nine at least it
you know they had next-gen what's going
on their voyager which is a bit more
a bit more similar i mean i've got my
own issues with voyager whatever um
enterprise
didn't do particularly well because of
you know
et cetera et cetera but um
you know uh the the movies were very
successful and um i personally really
like the movies and
think what you want about enterprise
what i would say though with with star
wars it's a different kettle of fish
because this is not a long running tv
show this is literally bam bam bam three
movies bam bam bam three movies so
you've got the original trilogy very
much george lucas's vision um
but
he didn't have three movies planned out
initially he um he had some ideas
and it it came about
as much a mixture of his ideas and also
editors editors doing a massive amounts
of work reigning them in um and
different directors for the last two
movies then the the prequel trilogy came
out and don't get me wrong i it's not a
masterpiece in my opinion but there's a
lot of good things going on there and i
mean i was very young when it came out
and i was running around
dressed as an older man looking back on
it
yeah there's some fault but there's a
lot of heart there there's a lot of
heart and i feel like the sequel trilogy
for me
there isn't any heart in it i feel like
it's it's it's death by committee i feel
like you've got a
a bunch of people sat there throwing out
ideas you know and um and basically it's
it's the product of a writer's room that
isn't necessarily
styles fans you know they're they're
they're not people who've been fans of
the you know the movie all the genres
for years of their life they're they're
people that are
hollywood executives who want to make a
a popular science fiction movie right
you know that's my opinion at least to
the sequel trilogy i don't know about
you guys
right we're gonna kill which of the
original cast are we gonna kill in this
film
and then which of the thing and there's
just it's feeling very formulaic
that's the thing
you say
but jar jar binks survives you know
let's kill this guy this guy can but no
let's leave jar jar alone he must live
to the to the heat death of the what's
the point now isn't it he has to live
yesterday
is just jar jar being i mean it was just
what about those bloody little
penguin things how those are so cute
little things i love them okay so so i i
think like
stormy you go
oh i'll just you know uh
chewy roast them and over uh
so i mean i suppose my point basically
and this applies to and this is why i
wanted to introduce both elements as
well is because for me i think one of
the issues both star trek and star wars
has is a lack of cohesive vision so
um giving you guys some examples so um
deep space nine ran for seven seasons
right and i had three producers
tng ran for seven seasons i had five
producers right
star trek discovery season two which for
me was where it went wrong had 14
producers
[Music]
for one season
11 producers right and we all know with
star wars that it had an entire team of
producers and writers and all of that
and i i feel like in a way these guys
have met death by committee because i
know star trek you know it was george
lucas but he had a bit of help however
you look at how the mandalorian went
when it had a proper show runner who was
passionate about the subject
flipping fantastic you know and and you
look at initially when they relaunched
star trek with discovery season one
yeah there was a bunch of producers but
discovery season one was a really good
season of star trek and i think what's
happened is that they've almost got to a
death by committee thing where they're
it's basically
can i swear
a little bit don't say this who's poor
planning pissed for planning basically
they they start the series and they've
got no plot outline and then what ends
up happening is and this particularly
happened with picard is they have
writer's room drama where basically
everybody's going in there and they've
all got ideas and instead of the
plot serving the scenes the scenes are
serving the plot so they come up with oh
wouldn't it be cool if we had a ball
cube and another renegade uh romulan
group
there are so um there are so many bits
that cross over there that's my point
jay is that there are so many bits
well yeah star wars you know started out
with you know has the same kind of
problems i mean when uh episode four
five and six you know lucas directed the
first one and other people directed the
the sequels while he was
you know
getting you know lucasfilm off the
ground and uh the effects and everything
else was going on
when it came to episode one two and
three but there's a long period of time
in lucas's life which went from the end
of episode um
six two when he started with one
is by the time they got to one no was
nobody on in hollywood that would tell
lucas no
yeah
yes star wars episode 4 was um
edited by his ex-wife his wife yeah yeah
she's
well at that time they were married
right right right do i have that
right
yeah and i'm pretty sure she told him no
a lot
but it was really tight so it was just
collaborative effort all the way through
i mean lucas will come on the set for
episode five and six and well this is
what and this is this is sure but you
know the directors did the directing
thing but well they they
i mean they asked they actually asked um
david lynch to direct the uh sixth
episode return of the jedi and he turned
it down uh because after dune he didn't
want to work with a major sci-fi
production however
um as you were saying storm it's a case
of though yes there's lots of people
involved but it's sort of one man's
vision that is then molded into
something constructive as opposed to
nowadays it's an entire room full of
people with conflicting ideas that all
want to
get whatever they want out there
yeah i agree
but i think across the three films in
particular though there's three very
different
i don't think there's like a um identity
to star wars i think there's a style i
think there's a cinematic style to the
films and you can pretty much
go wherever you want with the stories
but there's it's got to feel like star
wars yeah i agree
the three films though there's a very
different sort of styles the um the the
one is basically like a comedy and was
it the last one of the the the middle
film i was forgetting there was the one
where um luke dies
it was the second was it
are the three what what do you mean the
star wars films when luke luke skywalker
dies
oh you're sorry you're talking about
[ __ ]
the flipping sequel trilogy yeah i don't
that was that was the second film that
sucked
um but that was almost like a comedy in
that film there's always way it comes
down like
on all these sort of bits it was very it
didn't [ __ ] with star wars it slapped
like
comedy
well i i mean i've i'm sorry i feel like
i'm constantly talking over you guys but
i i i fully agree with you i think um
one of the main issues with
i miss this actually applies for both
star trek and star wars is that
they don't take themselves seriously
enough
or in the case of the card they take
themselves too seriously so what i would
say there is in the initial so let's
look at it from both angles so we look
at star wars right
it's contextual comedy why do people
laugh you know people laugh when
princess leia calls
han solo a nerf herder and and kisses
her brother
um you know
um versus in the new star trek series
it's like oh you're your mother
and it's like
all that's happening there is you're
taking away from the severity of the
situation because in the initial series
all of the comedy was contextual so it
was based around the situation you were
in whereas what they're what they've
tried to do in the sequel trilogy is
inject comedy in like a marvel style
with lots of quips
and that isn't star wars that's marvel
because that's how marvel has been since
the beginning but that's not star wars
so trying to turn it yeah trying to turn
star wars into a quippy thing
um
a it doesn't work because i was in the
cinema and most people like what the
hell was that didn't make any sense uh i
mean secondly
what you're doing is is star wars is
supposed to be taken seriously darth
vader serious threat grandma tarkin
serious threat the emperor serious
threat if you've got one of your like
squadron leaders and they're making your
mama jokes
against them
that is diminishing the threat of the
enemy which diminishes the threat in the
story which which makes the whole thing
unravel because you're not threatened by
the bad guys then are you
because they're a joke to the audience
you know and it's the same as um
[Music]
ray
not struggling against them it's a case
of like you know people people go oh
yeah you don't like rey as a star wars
protagonist because she's a she's a
female i only give a fine [ __ ] like i
think um you know star trek uh discovery
michael burnham's a great protagonist
love michael burnham fully on board
great vulcan dealing with emotions
doesn't always make the right decisions
ray always makes right decisions and
always has the expertise for whatever
situations he's in never experiences any
hardship so how is that a a story we can
enjoy there's no growth there there's no
character she does grow through the
films
does she do
well and she you know she had some
hardship because she grew up on the ass
end of the galaxy you know alone i mean
that's kind of a hardship yeah but
that's but that's that's telling not
showing ah i see
you're told that she's had hardship but
you're not shamed she's had hardship but
she's actually that's a clown
she's like
living in that
ship engine like you know scavenging and
she's got all the skills and everything
so
i'm just i'm just saying i've studied
literary theory so it's like a case of
basically for me
if somebody
if if i'm told somebody has had it hard
but i'm not shamed somebody has had it
hard
do i know they've had it hard you have
to be shown the hardship because
otherwise that doesn't show you
character development you need to see
how they've developed you can't just be
told they've had it r before but now
they haven't
that that that's there's no emotional
reaction to that
with her i think they did a similar sort
of thing in the other in the original
movies in that that luke went from
knowing nothing to being a jedi really
quickly
and it was sort of like that with her as
well there was she just all of a sudden
luke luke had nothing going on from the
first in the first movie
the only thing he did is struck one
lucky shot that was it right yeah in the
second movie he could he got
knocked out by a a freaking snow beast
who could barely lift his lightsaber
then went out to train right failed his
training and then got his [ __ ] hand
cut off by darth vader and then in the
third movie even then
he almost got beaten up on the barge and
then had to
prove himself against his dad
and and his victory wasn't about being
good at fighting his victory was
not fighting
that was luke skywalker with ray it was
right i've never picked up a lightsaber
but i'm going to defeat so-and-so i've
i've never swam but i'm going to swim
better than anyone i've never done
anything but i'm going to be the best at
it han solo's have a millennium falcon
for 30 years but i know how to bypass a
compressor
the whole millennium falcon bit
pissed me off after admitting that
it's done it's done it's stupid it was
the way they did it was stupid i loved
it when han solo stepped on the bridge
and went chewie we're home
my hairs did sort of go oh i enjoyed
that but it it made no sense it was so
lazy the way they did and this is my
point and this is my point about when
people go oh yeah you only don't like
the new star wars because ray's a girl i
don't i don't care i loved discovery and
discovery had a female lead i loved it
because she was flawed and she had to
learn and develop lessons and create
friendships and and
you know move forward as a character ray
didn't raven
everything
i bet uh spence you also liked rogue one
female driver i loved rayquaza i loved
you know that
best bit about rogue one the last 10
seconds
yes yes and that film are incredible
that was one of those posters
that was so good i liked rogue one
though because they took
um
a bit of the story that everyone knows
and they they filled it out they're that
stupid robot which i wasn't on board
with it was a little irritating but
they've always got to have one
irritating character
something like they do on purpose
um
voiced by um wash from
fluffy what was it i think alan
um two dicks
um
but uh
you know i was talking to somebody but
last week about um if they did a remake
of firefly if you have one character to
bring back it would have been wash
um but they killed him
idiots
i know that's stupid he was he was also
very good in um
[Music]
oh what's it called doom patrol
yes
yes he was very good patrol great
i'm a huge i'm a huge brendon phaser fan
i've been phrasing you know
um two dick in um that new series he did
i've kind of called now
where he plays an alien and he's trapped
on earth and he hates oh everybody
it's fantastic i cannot wait for the
sequel he's a genuinely brilliant sci-fi
and um he just hates everyone who keeps
talking to himself all the way through
and he's like trying to talk himself
after murdering everybody because i i
could just kill him and that that that
would solve my problem so i think and
then he has to like talk himself out and
not do it
that's fantastic serious
um i can't wait for the series to
um but yeah i forgot what's
up my style wasn't it we were trying to
i can i can oh no you guessed him
oh i was just saying we were talking
about star wars
the committee kind of thing
and
filmmaking in terms of long-term
projects
i think it's always been a problem you
know um
i mean there's lots of beloved series
that
change directors change producers over
and over and over um
uh
but with the good ones but with a good
one storm
don't they always
keep the message or expand upon it as
opposed to trying to completely recreate
it i mean i i'd argue though that like
like marvel
you've got that the head of the ship and
his name has gone out of my head
how many times have we seen his name
he's now chief executive of at disney
kevin kevin fee kenny faye um he's
always been the head of the ship though
isn't he always that [ __ ] keeps it on
and this is and this is what i was
saying about george lucas is and and um
you know very much say the same with
mandalorian you know it's it's one
person's passion project
yep
well yeah there's two
is spence freeze he's frozen
there's a more embarrassing expression
on his face can we look at that
um
we can poke fun of him enough because
but you know uh
there's two series that leap to mind
that uh went through all sorts of
turmoil still
still a fan favorite
uh one is the old soap opera series that
was on in america i don't know if it
ever made it to uk dark shadows
yes well we saw that the film was
released that long ago as well wasn't it
with them
yeah it is just this was like started in
the 60s and there was this whole series
of it was just another soap opera on
american television and then the um
it was going to get canceled
and so the creator of it says well let's
just go out with a bang and so all of a
sudden there's a vampire
yeah and it went on forever plus all the
series et cetera et cetera and i think
another one is
uh
doctor who
it has been
reinvented and reinvented
flows doctor it's popular then it's not
and it's pop we're in a low web at the
moment it's not very popular at the
moment
and uh i think a lot of that
you know when you have disruption like
that i think the thing that in terms of
starch wars the thing that was really
disrupted the most
was solo
because they had i can't remember the
two uh guys that were originally um
directing it
but you know the actors went to the
producer and complained this is i don't
even know what the [ __ ] this is
you know she and i guess is kathleen
kennedy that the one yeah
that they ratted it out to
and you know
how many times have we seen that in the
last few years when i mean look what
they did this schneider with um you know
justice league oh justice league yeah
that would never have happened under
marvel because kevin feige would never
have let it happen you know you've like
said you've got the captain of the ship
you've got somebody steering him in the
right direction
um
that's one of the things i worry now
that it's disney they've got star wars
and i think it is spencer's got it's
down right this it's it's by committee
and they keep
everything's i think good ideas go in
one end and they just get the crap
kicked out of them and they summit comes
out the other end but then you get but
it's why mandalorian worked because you
got favreau
who obviously loves the the genre he
loves the the project
and is the captain the ship he wrote
several of the episodes he directed a
few and but even when he hasn't he's
still that executive producer in charge
making sure it's going in the right
direction and even though i actually
didn't like mandalorian when it first
came out
i thought it was boring
um i then just
adored it he's back
um sorry why is my internet went down
uh we got to talk for a minute it was
great it was wonderful
[Laughter]
sorry
but i honestly think that was that's an
interesting point is that that when
there's somebody
in control the captain of the ship
keeping it on the right direction we can
like say we can list examples we're just
saying expense this example is of when
there isn't that one person
um
dc
all over the bloody place
and marvel they've got kevin feige keeps
it all in the right direction
the solo movie
was oh god yeah where they they
fired everybody involved and then
and changed them halfway through yeah
and you can tell in the film i i to be
honest i think they got that film wrong
from the start
the casting's wrong
they shouldn't i think they shouldn't
have even thought about making a film i
hate prequels they shouldn't they
shouldn't have bothered
um and i think it was doomed
from day one but then they just they
just they just kicked the crap out of it
as they went along as well
is it is it bad jay that i actually
quite enjoyed so though
yeah we have opposite opinions and
you're wrong about a lot of things
i like
but i also write about a lot of things
you know the you know the um
i like the origin story bit you know
between uh
and chewie that was kind of fun and
that's good
other glimpses of
the empire especially getting the [ __ ]
kicked out of them in just the worst
parts of the galaxy so we always see the
shining ships and the death stars but
this was like you know
it looks like you know at least the
scenes were where they met it was oh
here's the empire's version of vietnam
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i hadn't seen that before and that was
it was it was good it was good
i i found it for everything that the
film went through the story and the
production because remember ron howard
was stuck with a a steaming pile of [ __ ]
i mean he a lot of the original uh
uh scenes he just had to oh he looked at
all the reels and
well i say footage
well footage is even wrong in the
digital age
and
he said he saw what he had and he knew
what he'd have to do to correct some of
the things along and then he just
started reshoot some reshooting and then
a lot of additive stuff
and with with the the absolute
[ __ ] that the production was i
think ron howard did an admiral job to
bring out a
yeah damn right
let's not pretend it's not rogue one
it's not wrong don't shoot me in the
comments but i i thought it was it was a
it was a good effort on his part and he
really did save the movie i mean it was
powerful
actually
you should say that
it's funny
but it was still bad
it wasn't bad it was boring i don't
think it was i thought it was really
good i enjoyed saying i know it's i tell
you what no it's genuinely forgettable
as we're talking about i'm going oh yeah
everybody
the film and it's um i mean you you you
know you had the sexual tension between
vision and uh daenerys stormborn you
know
it was just
yeah but no no no storm storm you've
just you've literally proved a point
there where the only reason that you
care about those characters because
they've been other characters
between charleston you're right though
she's been in two big franchises and
she's ruined both of them
um
the dragon queen
when she was in terms
of three mate
but well no she did she didn't ruin game
of thrones
which is
as soon as she stopped getting her boobs
out because she got too powerful i i was
not interested
in that
she had a bit of respect stop trying to
show what i'm getting the hate meal for
this show oh yeah yeah dear
self-respect i lost interest
okay so let's let's know
she's brilliant in it
but she was terrible
she was terrible in solo
she did okay
a couple other films since so they were
great but
sorry okay so that's fine i'm just
saying like i was i was going to bounce
off something you said a minute ago
which is about
uh copy pacing ships
yeah so it's in case of like okay so
one thing about star trek fans and star
wars fans is they're big
geeks and they love
ship designs right okay now
george lucas george lucas made a very
awkward prequel trilogy however he did
you know have a team that came up with
some very nice original designs you know
you think about the naboo fighters you
know these yellow planes with the you
can picture it in your mind can't you
there's a long sweeping yeah exactly can
you picture in your mind any of the
ships in picard
yes because i hate it
okay it's it's memorable from
sales
that's a federation ship the um ship
that they fly around on um
yeah okay but any of the new ship
designs for me were like super generic i
could not draw you a picture of what any
like okay so they're they're flying
around in a new federation ship i could
i could not draw you that [ __ ] i could
not draw no i should have been talking
generally it always reminded me do you
remember the game wipe out
when kids wipe out yes yes yes on psx
yeah the ship that fly around in picard
you ship go back and have a look at
wipeout it's just they've just copied
and pasted it from one of those
designs from that very angle
there's two there's two tests which i
applied to picard and they they both
were messed up which is one
is a design test which is okay it's a
space drama can you draw the [ __ ]
they're in
no
okay so okay so the new characters okay
can you describe the new characters
without describing what they look like
or what they do
[Music]
okay can you describe rafi let's let's
do this as
a question
who is rafi
um i know the actress from other things
so yeah i mean
quite slightly
as the character
what what's her character
drug addict
burnout alcoholic
depressed
yeah but those that but these are you
know
that's that's exactly like that's not a
that's not a characteristic
it's
it's one it's very one-dimensional so
yeah exactly and it's the same thing
with okay so so let's let's do rios so
describe rios
now i like krios but but again i like
the apple okay so
what is he what's his character he's
he's a bit of a han solo sort of
character i thought he's a bit of a bit
of a renegade
but actually very very good talking
about the emh
i was like i
um
the thing about han solo is han solo is
a multi-dimensional character because
han solo acts like that but he's also a
hero and he also comes back at the last
bit and all of this what does rios do
well rios does he mean he does come back
and he does actually like
um does he i think he does develop as it
goes along but there isn't that big
thing at the end
but now i'm agreeing with you that there
isn't sort of like he doesn't have that
moment
when solo back at the standard star wars
which
is which is
is character development which is
something that picard lacks
the picard lacks lots of things when i
would agree
you're saying
the ships right these this cut and paste
ships they did at the end where the only
thing they changed the warp the cells a
little bit there's there's things about
the ship that i i hate for one they look
they just look crap
the cgi they look really awful
but the designs are crap the only thing
i liked about it is underneath the belly
there's four lights
and it always reminds me of that episode
you know
live
so basically the only reason that you
enjoy it is because it reminds you of
the better era of star trek yeah the
much much better picture i mean
you have to look at it
do you remember the the battle of war
three five nine at the beginning of deep
space nine in the first episode they
made a point of making all of the
starships look different because it
because you know starfleet is not a
military operation it's a science
operation so you've got all these
different things and even when in um
deep space nine battle of angels
when they went against the dominion
all of the ships looked [ __ ]
different because you know and it's like
how can you spend one third of the
amount of production costs on that
episode but still have individual ships
whereas when they all turn up at the end
of the card they're exactly the same
it just it shows no love
design's bad where the deflector should
be yeah there's um a cargo bay
if you line up that that ship next to
the enterprise a the cargo bay the front
of that belly is as wide as the
enterprise a yeah yes
and again it's like they've never met a
trekkie i say that in the video i just
did this
and this is my whole point is it's it's
not a series designed by people that
love star trek it's a series designed by
people who want to encourage people that
don't like star trek to watch star trek
but the whole point of star trek is
we're [ __ ] nerds we care about this
[ __ ] the thing that i've learned about
this conversation between you two
is that
and and i say this with all sincerity
and
when amazon's lord of the rings series
gets done
holy cat crap is there going to be
something to discuss
if you think
that the star wars fandom or the star
trek fandom is bigger than the tolkien
fandom
you're so wrong on all ends and
if you read the twitter feeds man i mean
there is great despair and furious anger
about uh what amazon may or may not
do
to the silmarillion and that's a future
show
but i'm just telling you
[Music]
all i i mean all right there's
you're coming
dude i i
honestly don't care about lord of the
rings i'm like i'm one of those few
people
i'm done talking with him i don't know
who spencer is
he's an idiot
well i know what i'm saying what i'm
saying is i don't i don't personally
care about lord of rings but i can
appreciate the anger that people
experience because like
i'm such a star trek fan and i can you
know
i can i can see star trek going wrong
and i'm like ah
no you know so it's infuriating
it is it is infuriating but i i was
worried about picard from the first
episode
um i genuinely was terrified but do you
think the influence of because you
mentioned amazon there norms amazon was
the was the driving force behind the
card but also lower decks
um
and then obviously got netflix was sort
of the influence behind discovery do you
think
the companies
i know they're all on cbs open action in
america aren't they open access
now it's just paramount plus
yeah it was oh
still behind the production though isn't
it so is there is there an influence you
think they have said look it needs to be
different discovery
you guys have both watched discovery
haven't you yes
do you feel like you've got a good grasp
over the story of picard
it's very forgettable
the uh for me it was like the um the
salvation of the romulan people was like
his
last hurrah you know there was all these
things that he did you know
between the the films and this
when it picks up the the the romulan uh
i just i mean for me for me it's okay
stuff right okay so i loved discovery
season one right i loved it okay there's
a lot of inconsistencies
a lot of people didn't like michael
burnham blah blah i loved it i thought
it was great i thought season two was
great but it got a bit boring you know
i hated picard i thought picab was like
nonsensical
and um
yeah i i was hoping if you guys have
both watched picard like can we just do
a quick
story analysis of this are you guys cool
with that it doesn't sure
it doesn't really
make sense but the very simple story is
obviously got all the romulan thing and
then you've got the data
okay so let me let me go right okay so
maddox made soji and dodge 37 months
beforehand right
and they sent dodge to earth and soji to
the ball cube to investigate the reasons
behind the synth attack on mars
yeah yeah
okay
so
if it if
if maddox did that
why did they erase their memory
so that they uh yeah yeah no true but
then
if they don't yes because
how does how does that help the
investigation like have he meant to know
what they're looking for or get the
information or feed it back to it
sub programming
okay cool so no it doesn't
make sense but it's a good story
so
so also
why why did he send soji to the
reclamation project
because the reclamation project has
nothing to do with sense
my assumption was to hide her
because the reclamation project was so
kinda secret
oh i could dasher here and she you know
but it was also populated by the the
the romans so
you know people that were programmed to
be terrified
why did he even send her in the first
place to that location because
you know it's it's not a it's not
anything to do with themselves it's just
balls so you need to meet picard
why because maddox didn't like picard in
next-gen
no no no but i mean yeah but he
obviously might have developed a respect
from his time went on the whole maddox
okay so
all right okay so so if he did send it
for that purpose right
um
basically there was narak and narissa
who were
basically only there for her
um
so is this a uh
basically it's a a jad mirage
thing or is it a romulan thing
the the the ball reclamation cube
it's no it was the it's the thing isn't
it it's not the romulans
it was supposed to be talia and like
what you said that um oh god i can't
pronounce it
supposed to be a secret society
yeah but yeah but i know because it is
the wrongness because it's i think the
romulans have got hold of it because
it's it's the only
thing they've got sort of thing it's
it's the one thing that the romulan
empire got left because they've got they
haven't got a home world they haven't
got anything okay but but it but at the
same time they say that it's a it's a
collaborative effort with the federation
which is why picard has allowed access
because he has diplomatic access because
he is part of the federation
so if it's if it's uh
do you see where i'm coming from
the
let me let me add a little bit more plot
hole to this uh let me just start off
with uh going back to rios just for a
second
i think the character of rios
it was like um
he had multiple personalities and the
multiple personalities well he did yeah
what was it was the uh holograms you
know there was the navigator and there's
a scene with trying to integrate all the
uh you know on in uh picard's office is
just trying they're all the holograms
are there and then rios is there
and i really thought that well no rias
is not there but anyway i thought that
that a lot of the character of rius was
also made up a lot of the holograms
said you know when you asked me like you
know what what do i say think the plot
uh was
for a picard i think well you know
picard's growing some grapes
uh he sees david
pitch on fire and then he blows seven of
nine shipped to smithereens and then
seven of nine takes out takes the weight
of the uh the rex the rest of the uh
the uh
the story until
the solution you know is it to me the
picard
the the thing i remember and i really
think about that i thought was type was
just stat 709 story arc the rest was
just in caps
seven of nine is is actually probably
the best thing in the series by quite a
long way oh god yeah
and um
the other thing that we're talking about
we're talking about you know the the
cube and why do the romulans have them
well
the thing that we really don't talk
about or no one's really
discussing is
voyager destroyed
the board yeah they did yeah and we're
just arguing over now the buoyancy
didn't destroy the ball
they didn't they they destroyed a trans
warp conduit that was one of five they
didn't destroy the dog they didn't
through or they just destroyed one
nexus
exactly there was supposed to be five of
them
um
seriously harmed also i'm just kidding
as well
in there that transit
for the queens so the thing is we the
the this whole premise it totally
ignores
all the other borg all the other cubes
and we're all wrapped up about this one
singular cube
and it just oh there's more board you
know there's other stuff yeah this is
this is the whole point though and it's
just like
you're just arguing
oh we've got we've got one ball cube you
know it's like there's [ __ ] hundreds
of ball cubes out there that's the whole
[ __ ] point about morgan's very
intimidating you know it's not just one
ball cube that's what and this is my
whole point about the show it's like
it's [ __ ] it doesn't make any sense
you know
what you why why oh we've wrecked we've
reclaimed one ball cube i'm like dude
you would have reclaimed like [ __ ] 50
ball keeps at this point
why are you nagging out about it there's
also the space
testicle tentacle thingies that start
coming through the thing that's right
yeah that is the least terrifying that
was supposed to be oh my god this is the
end of the universe it was the least
terrifying end of the universe i've ever
seen the romulans sort of went they
started to come through
i was like
okay
um these techno whatever they're
supposed to because they don't look that
scary to me
everything about picard was just
crap the the the only thing is nice
i'll tell you what i feel like here we
go right
so um
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna invite you
focus stormy and jamie to answer this
question right
okay so
we're ready here we go let's let's let's
go let's go star trek
malux made soji and dodge
months ago and sent dodge to earth and
soji to the ball cube to investigate the
reasons behind the synth attack on mars
that's right yeah yeah
that's super cool
yeah okay so
why did
maddox erase their memories because does
that not
impede the investigation
and
if so how are they meant to know that
they're looking for anything and how are
they meant to know
how to
send that back home once they find that
information it doesn't make any sense i
thought okay
my impression was that maddox did that
to uh hide bits of himself
it was to protect him
i mean
the way the story kind of chunked along
on square wheels it was just
it was like you know maddox had
something to hide and says well you know
let's just hide all this evidence eraser
but the thing is is that like once once
they discover that how do they get that
back to him
because they're not supposed to know who
he is yeah but her her programming
started to activate when she learned
differently but once she activated she
still didn't know who she was
when she activated when doris activated
she fought off a couple of tower shower
agents but she doesn't know who she was
no she didn't know what she was supposed
to be doing there but she's very
attracted to pinot noir apparently
so much
oh yes but you know basically like so so
after that so so
soji was sent to the reclamation project
but why was she sent to the reclamation
project because what does a reclamation
project have to do with androids
well the other thing that cross promotes
you know i've got all these strange
theories because the thing like i said
that's good i want to hear it it was a
story built on square wheels and so i've
got all these strange things the reason
maddox was sent her to the board cube
was he had some other project he was
working on that never even made it to
the script i'm thinking you know well
maybe she had another mission that was
different from her sisters
you know and i mean i mean which is bad
storytelling because storytelling is
supposed to be oh i'm not trying to
defend the story yeah i mean oh my god
in heaven i think she's at the
reclamation
thing because she had to be
because the writers needed to place it
there to push the story forward exactly
which which is
it's bad it's lazy storytelling as well
as the one they don't this it's not
complicated the only thing in that
series which which i honestly i think is
really good
um is seven of nine and i'm really
interested to see
where the 79 character goes now she's
basically the new queen
and that that's going to be really
interesting arc
picard series 2 is worrying the crap out
of me
already from the adverts with q and i'm
like oh they've forced the cue back into
it
picard
i love patrick's duties one of the
greatest actors
i'd love him to death but the man can
barely walk
yeah you know
really limits
the believability
i checked
on your point man on your very point you
know when um
so just when she explodes right i think
his episode he's knocked back 90 feet
exactly how much titanium was put into
his head
holy [ __ ] i mean if i got knocked i mean
if i fall down i'm if i just fall i'm
going to sprain something no he's broken
i mean picard flew halfway across san
francisco
yeah the bit he's about to have a sword
fight for the wrong
completely disengaged from rio i was
like oh [ __ ] you're kidding me he's
about to have a sword fight with a
romulan i know this old guy's about to
get into him
like i i felt the sword fight for romeo
was very own character for picard it was
our character i thought it was
completely on character 900 year old
picard could barely lift the sword
no no my problem is it's not the thing
it's the actor he's just too old to do
like an action series basically it's not
it's the wrong
no i know he's not but he's not doing an
accent series and this is my whole point
i don't want to do an accessories i want
him to do like a
you know somewhere
between but i'm sorry i had the worst
thought
there's a reason why professor x's
xavier is in a wheelchair i'm just
saying
patrick shoot really needed to sit down
that's actually really interesting
we might be british but you know
don't get racist about it
racist
i'm joking i'm sorry
my legs have stopped working now
you've enjoyed yourself this evening
so no um yeah basically it's a case of
you know you've just got to make sure
that your
your captain's managing his
[ __ ] his experience
yeah
so
because we're going to wrap it up
because we've only got five minutes
um
has the the question we came in to
answer was has as star trek and star
wars that we've barely mentioned
and lost their identity right
and i'll just say the thing i don't
think star wars has i just think they've
made a couple of bad movies
and i think mandalorian is bang on
what star wars is and i think it's
phenomenal
i think star trek
has always there's always been good star
trek there's always been bad star trek
and you've got to go and watch series 3
of disco because it is actually getting
really good
um
and i hope stranger worlds will be
fingers crossed
but lower decks is the best star trek
it's the most star trek star trek
and you know in terms of science fiction
and just terms of pure science fiction
storytelling you know um
the original animated series
but back in one second
was was really fun
you know and so um
anyway i'll close you know because we've
been only talking about the tv the
broadcast stuff the television series or
the movies
and there's still a a huge
breadth and depth of storytelling for
both uh uh stories star wars and star
trek in books and comic books and um
some of those do well
some of those really hit hard and uh
some don't
did we lose spence
yeah basically i mean stormy sums it up
like you know
i'll tell you what you can be a big fan
of star trek or star wars it doesn't
matter you know
if you're into the new [ __ ] or the old
[ __ ] it doesn't matter as long as you're
interested in it
we can all get on so
i have a great night people
uh yeah i'm gonna watch it all
you know
yeah damn right damn
jamie's back what are you going to watch
all what are you going to watch uh
whatever they pre you know you know if
we're good or bad i'll end up watching
you know what we need to do is we need
to do a um uh the three of us all watch
the star trek movie and invite people to
watch it with us
it'd be so much fun
i think that's gonna be our next thing
but we've got to do i'd be amazing like
we could whack it on and be so good
yeah and just just again just like i'm
gonna do um so that i wanna do like some
of the best episodes as well from the
series and just sort of tear them apart
i don't know how you get around the uh
the copyright issues but we'll figure it
out but actually you just don't do you
just we just have some you watch in the
background i think you just don't have
it on screen but jamie the thing i was
not mentioning is that we one thing we
didn't cover was the breadth and depth
of uh the books that's been published
over the last
and four decades
some of those hit well and some of them
are miserable
you know um i actually really liked the
ones william shatner wrote for star trek
um i thought they were really good i
thought there was a great writer in the
world we loved star trek
i mean i remember one of the first star
trek star wars books i read was a
splinter of the mind's eye
you know and it came out god when they
kind of 80 something maybe but it was
kind of canon it kind of wasn't but it
was it was it was entertaining to read
you know it helped uh you know expand
the universe at least for me a lot of
the graphic novels they're great and i'd
like to start to use the graphic novels
really well because i mean the the
graphic novel before picard came out uh
countdown
um
actually really fed into the series
normally they're like way off cannon and
they're not they're nothing to do with
the shows really they're just you know a
bit of fun sort of thing or whatever and
but that one actually like gave you all
the background for the suit they used
the graphic novel to set up the show
and we actually see a um a pegasus class
pegasus
whatever the enterprise f is supposed to
be i want to say pegasus but i'm think
i'm wrong but anyway we actually see
that class of starship which makes me
excited thinking oh could we actually
see the enterprise f
in picard in the in the next couple of
series
um because they've sort of hinted at it
in the comic book
yeah and everything else in the comic
book kind of is uncanny you know it's
like they introduce his you know the
romulan
um servants
and all that sort of thing in the
countdown series and it's like it's it
actually is like a
i think they've used it to get people
excited and i think that's that was
really clever they should be doing that
in the future
i am protected
um
but yeah some of the um some of the
graphic novels have been excellent but
also the the online star trek online
something that we haven't spoken about
as well is some of the fan
um projects some of the fan films and
things that they've done over the years
some of them have been really really
good mate honestly like you know um
bloody uh
oh god wasn't it
there's so many fantastic people
involved in that
they had uh
two lock two lock was in it
yep two vodka well actually um um
chekhov was in a couple
um but i mean but yeah they were
generally because then they're made by
people particularly in like the dark
ages between
sort of enterprise ending and um
and discovery starting you know when the
you know because without the jj abrams
films we probably wouldn't have any star
trek if they was just lucky they were
popular
when we had those dark ages there were
fans making
you know making films and making youtube
videos and things and things they were
great
and then yeah not even no money but so
they should be that's kind of cut by the
chart really
but um and that's that's the thing for
me because i think you're right spencer
that you say that i think a lot of stuff
that we're seeing at the moment isn't
made by people actually love
the material
where that fan art and some of the
graphic novels some of the books and
things are made by people that really
love
the material
and that's you know and i i i'm a
stickler i like the canon i don't like
things to be changed and it's every so
often you see star trek episodes and go
no that's not right because whatever
happened in that other episode and you
know we argue about these things i hate
it when those things happen those
mistakes happen which is why i hate
prequels
because i'm i'm going to worry about
stranger worlds because
it really winds me up when they do that
and they mess with the cannon
what are they going to do i'm wondering
if the the method to introduce multiple
different timelines or whatever get off
cannon was his experience with with
pikes experience with the time crystal
yeah that that's what they'll end up
doing and then i'm messing around with
the time stuff again
and and i always think time travel
episodes are always they're either
they're really hit or miss they're
either brilliant or awful and there's
there's not much in between so i think
um but i don't like the time travel ones
myself
except voyage home which is obviously
the best star trek movie
so
when they go back and save the whales
don't pull a face spence while you're
falling asleep
just
the um actually my understanding which
is my favorite star trek film
i love undiscovered country
but only because it was the first one i
ever saw in the cinema and i skived off
school to go watch it
and then
and i loved it
and then the praxis explodes i was just
like sat there as a kid like skyping off
school in my uniform i don't know how
they let me in much skill time going
something this is awesome
oh my god yeah my favorite star trek
film by mile but because it's a good
personal reason isn't it because i was
there sort of thing come on
focus and get um
but yeah so have we answered the
question
i think so
i think
it kind of has and it kind of hasn't
lost everything but
cinema changes at the end of the day
and cinema might be dead so
um we're all going to be streaming which
in which case all of our tv shows are
going to be made by nexus or um
nexus netflix
disney nexus the one thing i was going
to say actually about disney having star
wars is if we know anything about
disney's they will
they will squeeze every last bit of
blood out of the stone that is star wars
and that's my worry about the future of
star wars
there's
about nine different projects planned
for star wars over the next five years
some of them are going to be brilliant
some of them are going to be awful
and um and i worry about that
i think we're going to be
like we all get star trek out a few
years ago and i think that was part of
the problem with enterprise when it came
along we just said ds now we'd have
voyage and people were bored of it
and it
it and it wasn't a very good show but i
think well i mean i think that's one
reason why we're bored of it is like
yeah do you say that tonight
it's just [ __ ] um
do you remember though when enterprise
got announced and they'd had scott
bakula as the captain i was just like
that
yeah that is the cleverest thing that's
ever been done this is going to be
awesome
and then i saw the chick that they had
playing in um the vulcan
i've forgotten her name now travol
and anyway and i thought yeah she's
beautiful i'm on board and then the
series was [ __ ]
but
anyway
thanks for joining us tonight guys it's
been very welcome
we're definitely gonna have a chat about
stranger worlds coming up very shortly
and um please get in the comments guys
if you want anything else for us to
discuss then please let us know and we
will
um have a think about it for future
videos and we'll see what spence is
going to do to himself next time
how do you how are you going to
how are you going to top that
i
[Laughter]
sexy i don't yeah i know i want
volcanoes now i want to see ferengi ears
on him you know foreign
with two massive plates
super glued to his head
do that
gonna
with super glue stop sticking your
tongue out spence
all right guys thank you very much and
um we'll see you next time
good night
thank you
oh